un lit cas le concert de la courneuve
pour l'aide à l'ethiopie n'a pas eu le
succès escompté les organisateurs
attendaient cent cinquante mille
personnes
il y en a eu dix fois moins l'important
comme l'ont dit certains chanteurs c'est
que le concert est eu lieu roland sicard
était là pour antenne 2 à la courneuve
champion artistes sur scène six heures
de spectacle et le public un public
enthousiasmé beaucoup moins nombreux que
prévu avec la place à 120 francs les
organisateurs ont peut être placé la
barre un peu haut notamment pour ceux
qui voulaient venir en famille un prix
élevé mais pour la bonne cause
tous les artistes étaient bénévoles et
le produit de la recette ira directement
en ethiopie
ça aurait des huissiers des audits qui
vont vérifier toute responsabilité de
toutes les recettes attenante et au
disque et au concert la plupart des
chanteurs ont demandé que ces garanties
soir
sur précisé
les organisateurs du concert espérer
recueillir 10 millions de francs
l'objectif ne sera pas atteint malgré
l'élan des 75 chanteur mais pour
l'ethiopie chaque fonds est utile
ouais
je
donc